[Music]
good afternoon and welcome
life is strange leaf hustling genetics
and evolutionary theory have combined to
give a seemingly watertight account of
life on earth yet scientists remain
uncertain and theories abound about just
how it got started we don't even have
angry definition of what life is as we
explore the planets of the solar system
and look at those beyond researchers
hope they'll find evidence of life but
would it be like life on earth would we
be able to identify it as life at all
or is the wish to find other life forms
the science fiction fantasy that serves
Hollywood but has little to do with
reality we have a very distinguished
panel to discuss these questions with us
Nick Lane is a biochemist focusing on
the origins of life and he argues that
complex life on Earth is a result of a
fluke occurrence billions of years ago
meaning that we are likely to be very
alone in the universe and to my
immediate right
we have Monica Grady who is a space
scientist and professor of planetary and
space science at the Open University too
far right as Ralph Cody
his head of future missions at Airbus
and specializes in engineering for new
scientific space missions and previously
worked for the European Space Agency
we'll start this event with three-minute
pictures from each of the participant on
the overall question of is the wish to
find other life forms a science fiction
fantasy and I think Nick if you start us
off from this ok so I I guess my answer
is supposed to be no from the way in
which I was introduced and I suppose I
mean what do we mean by science fiction
I think what science fiction tries to do
the best of science fiction is to
explore possible scientific futures and
I think
the search for life in space is very
much the frontier of science at the
moment so it's very much science fact
it's not science fiction what are we
actually looking for then what which
parts beginning to get more into the
realms of science fiction and I think
there's perhaps an argument to say well
we're too constrained in our imagination
life could be anything
there was a lovely quote from JBS
Haldane who said the universe is not
only more weird than the new imagined is
more weird than you can imagine and
there's almost certainly truth in that
but I think from my point of view as a
biologist I'm asking well what's life
why is life this way on earth are there
principles governing the trajectory the
evolutionary history of life on Earth
beyond you know population genetics and
selection there's sand of evolutionary
theory life actually took a very very
weird path on earth and so the question
is well can we extrapolate from that is
it fundamental can we say from the fact
that it complex life on Earth only arose
once in four billion years that
therefore there's some genuine
fundamental difficulty about it and I
would argue that there probably is and
that that might also play out elsewhere
in the universe in which case I'm not
saying that complex life doesn't exist
elsewhere is just that perhaps the the
the physicists hope you might say the
cosmologists hope is that life is
inevitable that it's seeded in the
universe and that really any planet as
suitable to sustain life will end up
with complex life like humans and I
would say that that is not a science
fiction view but probably an over
optimistic view and I think that the
likelihood is we will find bacteria
almost everywhere we look and that the
hope for a kind of Star Wars scenario or
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy which I
love by the way I will be surprised if
it came to pass so that's my tip thank
you and Nick what do you say about the
wish to find other life-forms in the
city science fiction fan well I think
there's a kind of journey through life
here you know when I was a small boy I
was a science geek of course astronomy
universe dinosaurs all those sorts of
things I haven't frankly I still AM of
course
aliens were everywhere
- whose Star Trek fantastic movies War
of the Worlds and generally they were
sinister they were powerful and they
were really rather dangerous - no now
thinking of alien life like that is that
actually a motivation for trying to find
life outside of the earth or or is it
just a reason for being very scared
about what might be out there well you
know I don't think that's got much to do
with the question about life or the
search for life
that's more about fears of other humans
about fears and threats here on earth
but kind of writ large and given a
spacey distance and veil of mystery um
basically you know we're we're faces we
would be facing things which were I
don't know more powerful than us but
just as destructive as us so I think you
have to grow up a little bit and start
to ask what sort of questions can we as
human beings not just as scientists ask
which are valid and scientific questions
science questions don't get generated by
a computer there's not some pre-written
agenda for scientific questions we are
just as capable as any scientists or
engineers in asking questions of course
there are certain questions that are
important today about how we live on
earth the climate our health natural
hazards things like that but also the
questions that we ask and we've asked
ourselves at night here we've come into
the universe knowing nothing about it
what is this universe thing we're in
what is life where did it come from are
we alone those are valid questions that
we can ask as the public and then the
exciting thing is to start thinking
about ways in which you can actually add
knowledge to that thinking about ways in
which you can start to chip away and
answer some of those questions
now some people go straight out and
listen out for alien radio broadcasts
okay
that's like trying to sort of you know
shake hands with them or something I
feel that still a bit linked to the
scary aliens picture of powerful beings
out there you know I used to be a used
to be a radio astronomer myself I
trained in radio astronomy and in my
very group a few years before me not so
very long before I was doing a PhD they
actually discovered signals beeps coming
from deep space regular beeps and you
may be you may have heard of the the
scientist who was leading that at the
time doing her PhD that was Jocelyn Bell
um so today we're not looking to shake
hands with aliens we're looking at
exciting ways to really answer questions
which are relevant to this questions
about the conditions on earth in the
past conditions on other planets in our
solar system and even conditions on
planets in other solar systems these are
realistic things to do now for
scientists and engineers but they are
linked to this big question that we all
ask okay money can't work remember what
the question was the person is the wish
to find other life forms a science
fiction fantasy no no it is not a
science fiction fantasy I think 30 years
ago it was a science fiction fantasy
because we didn't know enough about the
the range of life on Earth the types of
conditions that life could exist in we
didn't know about the possibilities of
planets around stars beyond our own we
didn't know about the types of life that
could exist in all sorts of niches in
Antarctica in the deep oceans and so on
and so forth
so it is not science fiction to want to
look for life beyond the earth
I think it is science fiction somewhat
as as as both my colleagues mentioned to
look for something that looks like us I
mean we are designed to operate in this
gravity we are designed to operate with
a particular solar radiation we are
designed to to deal with life on earth
life on Mars would look different life
on Europa would look different life on
you know one of the planets around
another star would look different
because every planet is different you
know even earth-like planets differ one
from another because Mars is an
earth-like planet so we're not going out
as scientists I don't think we're going
out to look for something that looks
like us 66 million years ago we would
have been looking for life that looked
like a dinosaur but then they were wiped
out and so the little furry mammals
could could evolve to to work to where
they've got to know and so things change
so you start off with the same materials
but they develop in in different ways
now Nick said that complex life I think
he said this only got going one for us
how do you know well we don't know but
there you go sort of thing that we don't
know what the original types of life
were on earth because they could have
got wiped out and they only the seed
that that germinated that that became us
only started 3.5 billion years ago so
there could have been other life forms
so we'll take up on that one for a
moment but first before we can even
discuss what we expect to find in space
let's try and define what life is the
podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute's of art
and ideas click the link on screen now
to ie TV